let's get back to the point Black Adam
you big opening huge by the way uh
the thing that's crazy about it being so
[__] big your fan base is engaged
everybody's engaged you make an
announcement and your announcement is
talking about hey we're not going to
continue the world of Black Adam right
uh for me I'm curious I want to know why
especially when they're such a
successful opening
um you seem to have the appetite from
your fan base for more what's the reason
or the reasons for the stopping of Black
Adam uh
I think that Black Adam got caught in a
Vortex of
new leadership and at that time as we
were creating Black Adam developing it
shooting Black Adam we got knocked down
a little bit for because of covid and
the shutdowns got back up there was so
many changes in leadership and as you
know anytime you have a company but
especially that size of magnitude that's
a publicly traded company and you have
all those changes in leadership you have
people coming in who
creatively fiscally are going to make
decisions that you may not agree with
philosophically so I think Black Adam
was one of those movies that got caught
in that web of new leadership
and you know that will always be one of
the um
one of the biggest mysteries I think not
only for me and us on our end but also
throughout our business because that's a
Kevin question but that has that was a
question out of Wall Street that was a
question out of Hollywood that was a
question like wait a second you had the
biggest opening of your career sure no
China that could have been maybe a
hundred maybe 200 more million dollars
um you're establishing a new superhero
you want to grow out the franchise you
bring back Superman and Henry Cavill the
world went crazy and also too and you
and I you were texting me this on
opening weekend is uh we created a
diverse
superhero portfolio where we had just
men and women of color uh you know in
Black Adam too as well so
um I think I was more
I was impressed by the execution yeah I
know I Black Adam how close the movie
was the project at night that was one
that was near and dear to your heart and
cracking the code it seemed that
cracking the code on the world of
superhero is something of course that
you were very ambitious about doing and
what I thought you did I was like oh
that's dope as [__] he put his mind to
it and he did it like the shit's
happening they're in production they're
shooting the movie [__] it's done damn
release the trailer [__] look good DJ
congrats [__] all right you then
released the movie movie has success
behind it you get some positive dollars
in the goddamn box office behind it in a
time where the box office uh seem to be
taking hits dips so I don't know it was
just it was a weird thing for me and
just not knowing but to hear you say
that it makes sense you know when
there's a Changing of the Guard
sometimes the business changes as well
and rightfully so right like we can't
exactly a part of the world of why yeah
on that side but
um and giving them the best opportunity
to make more and do more or that's our
job that's where we come in exactly and
you know I think it is as
business-minded people who are always
you and I who are always thinking
audience first yes we look at and
respect the bottom line economically but
also when you think about opportunity
and creating opportunity and creating
things that are fresh and delivering for
the audience which is our number one
boss
um
when when that wasn't looked at through
that lens it makes things a little bit
more challenging I think for guys like
you and I where you go you sure you want
to do this but hey at the end of the day
you know what it is it's like new
ownership coming in buying an NFL team
and going all right not my head coach
not my quarterback doesn't matter how
many times you won the Super Bowl
doesn't matter how many rings we got I'm
going with somebody great example yeah
that's a great example
[Music]